bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação na IBM
Quantum. Esta é a 10ª aula da série e é a segunda aula da terceira unidade, que trata da formulação geral
da informação quântica. Esta aula é sobre canais, que representam mudanças em
sistemas que armazenam informação quântica. Isso inclui operações úteis como as realizadas por
gates unitários e circuits quânticos, bem como mudanças que talvez prefiramos evitar, como ruído. Também podemos descrever medições
como canais, e isso é algo que abordaremos na próxima aula. O termo canal vem
da teoria da informação, que entre outras coisas estuda a capacidade de transmissão de informação de canais de comunicação com ruído
portanto, quando pensamos em canais, estamos pensando de forma abstrata sobre comunicação
canais. Pode parecer um pouco estranho pensar num cálculo complexo como um canal de comunicação, mas precisamos de
uma palavra para nos referirmos à noção geral de um processo que muda a informação de alguma forma, e para o bem ou para o mal, a palavra
canal ficou. Sem dúvida em grande parte devido ao enorme impacto que a teoria da informação, e em particular o
trabalho de Claude Shannon na década de 1940, teve na informação e computação quântica. Aqui está uma visão geral da
aula. Começaremos com o básico, incluindo a definição do que é um canal, bem como como as operações unitárias na formulação simplificada
da informação quântica podem ser descritas como canais. Também falaremos sobre o fato de que combinações convexas de canais são canais, e se você estiver
se perguntando por que essa noção de convexidade continua aparecendo, é porque ela realmente é uma noção matemática fundamentalmente importante na teoria da
informação quântica. Também veremos alguns exemplos de canais, especificamente canais de qubit, que reaparecerão de tempos
em tempos ao longo do restante da aula. Na segunda parte da aula, falaremos sobre três formas diferentes de representar canais
matematicamente e, em particular, falaremos sobre representações de Stinespring, representações de Kraus e
representações de Choi, que têm o nome de três pessoas cujo trabalho foi importante no desenvolvimento dessas diferentes representações. E na terceira e
última parte da aula, discutiremos uma prova matemática que estabelece que essas três representações são de fato equivalentes, além do fato de que elas
todas caracterizam corretamente a definição do que é um canal. É uma prova matemática muito elegante na minha opinião, e espero que acrescente alguma
clareza a essas diferentes apresentações, como se relacionam e como funcionam em geral. Começaremos com o básico e
abordaremos a questão: o que são canais? Como já sugeri no início da aula, canais descrevem mudanças
especificamente mudanças em tempo discreto em sistemas que armazenam informação quântica. Aqui, quando nos referimos a tempo discreto,
estamos apenas pensando em uma mudança que ocorre entre dois momentos distintos no tempo, em oposição a um
processo contínuo, por exemplo, que faz sentido pensar ao longo de períodos de tempo infinitesimalmente pequenos. Canais incluem operações úteis como
operações unitárias realizadas por gates e circuits quânticos, bem como mudanças devidas ao ruído. Por exemplo, para
os propósitos desta aula, porém, vamos principalmente pensar em canais em termos matemáticos abstratos, e não haverá necessidade particular
de distinguir entre o que é útil e o que não é. Nomes típicos para canais incluem as letras gregas maiúsculas fi,
psi e delta, e usaremos letras diferentes para nos referirmos a alguns canais específicos. Em uma situação simples em que
temos um sistema em um estado descrito por uma matriz densidade rho e aplicamos um canal fi a esse sistema,
o resultado é um sistema cujo estado é descrito pela matriz densidade fi de rho. Portanto, estamos pensando em um dado
canal fi como sendo uma função que pode ser aplicada a matrizes densidade de um tamanho específico, ou em outras palavras,
matrizes densidade de um sistema específico ao qual estamos aplicando esse canal. Há alguns requisitos que os canais precisam satisfazer para ser
considerados canais válidos. Primeiro, canais são mapeamentos lineares. Isso é completamente análogo à situação que temos tanto
na formulação simplificada da informação quântica, onde operações em vetores de estado quântico são necessariamente lineares,
quanto na formulação padrão da informação clássica, onde operações probabilísticas são lineares. Você poderia escolher questionar esse requisito básico
de linearidade se realmente quisesse, mas se quisermos uma teoria consistente tanto com a teoria da probabilidade
quanto com a escolha de representar estados quânticos com matrizes densidade, então realmente não temos escolha e simplesmente temos que aceitar que os canais são lineares.
O segundo requisito é que os canais transformem matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade. Isso faz todo sentido, porque se escolhemos representar
estados de sistemas com matrizes densidade e aplicamos um canal a um sistema que está em algum estado, o resultado tem que ser um estado válido e, portanto,
representado por uma matriz densidade. Há um ponto muito importante a acrescentar aqui, porém, que é que esse requisito
tem que ser verdadeiro não apenas se aplicarmos um canal a um sistema isolado cujo estado é descrito por uma matriz densidade,
mas também se temos um sistema composto cujo estado é descrito por alguma matriz densidade e aplicamos o canal apenas
a uma parte desse sistema. Então esses são os requisitos que impomos aos canais, e podemos ver que eles são muito
análogos aos requisitos que temos para operações tanto na formulação simplificada da informação quântica quanto na formulação padrão
da informação clássica. Na formulação simplificada da informação quântica, as operações são representadas por matrizes unitárias porque elas
correspondem precisamente aos mapeamentos lineares que sempre transformam vetores de estado quântico em vetores de estado quântico para um
dado sistema, e de forma análoga, as operações probabilísticas são representadas por matrizes estocásticas, porque essas são as que
sempre transformam vetores de probabilidade em vetores de probabilidade. Aqui estamos trabalhando com matrizes densidade, e há
esse requisito adicional relativo a sistemas compostos que não é necessário para vetores de estado quântico
ou vetores de probabilidade, mas ainda assim os requisitos são análogos e, em certo sentido, nos são impostos pela escolha
de representar estados quânticos por matrizes densidade. Aqui estão mais alguns detalhes sobre canais, incluindo uma convenção
de como pensaremos sobre os sistemas de entrada e saída de um canal ao longo da aula, bem como mais detalhes
sobre o requisito de que os canais sempre transformem matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade. Primeiro, todo canal
assume ter um sistema de entrada e um sistema de saída. Podemos nomear esses sistemas como quisermos, mas ao longo desta
aula vou usar o nome X para o sistema de entrada e o nome Y para o sistema de saída. Conceptualmente falando, o canal
transforma o sistema de entrada no sistema de saída, portanto os sistemas de entrada e saída nunca coexistem simultaneamente.
Começamos com X, o canal é aplicado ou executado, e o resultado é que X foi transformado em Y, cujo estado é
determinado pelo mapeamento linear associado ao canal. Os sistemas de entrada e saída de um canal não precisam ser os mesmos e, em particular,
não precisam ter o mesmo número de estados clássicos. Porém, pode ser que os sistemas de entrada e saída sejam de fato o mesmo sistema, ou em outras
palavras, X é igual a Y, caso em que estamos simplesmente imaginando que fi está mudando o estado do sistema, e de fato esta é
muito frequentemente a situação em que estamos interessados. Mas essa possibilidade é consistente com o primeiro ponto no sentido de que nunca temos os
sistemas de entrada e saída existindo como dois sistemas separados ao mesmo tempo. De qualquer forma, vai ser conveniente para
os propósitos desta aula usar letras diferentes, ou seja, X e Y, para nos referirmos aos sistemas de entrada e saída,
apenas para nos ajudar a manter as coisas em ordem. Agora vamos entrar em um pouco mais de detalhe sobre o requisito de que os canais sempre transformam matrizes densidade
em matrizes densidade. Vamos supor que introduzimos um novo sistema Z na imagem. Vamos
dar o nome gamma ao conjunto de estados clássicos deste novo sistema. Imagine agora que formamos um novo sistema composto ZX
consistindo do novo sistema junto com o sistema de entrada X de um canal fi, e suponha que esse sistema composto esteja
em um estado descrito por uma matriz densidade rho. Esse pode ser um estado quântico arbitrário desse par, mas qualquer que seja o estado,
é sempre possível expressar a matriz densidade rho na forma mostrada na tela, onde tanto A quanto B
variam sobre o conjunto de estados clássicos gamma, e cada rho_AB é alguma matriz cujas linhas e colunas correspondem ao
conjunto de estados clássicos de X. Não precisamos dar um nome a esse conjunto de estados clássicos neste ponto. Só para deixar claro, cada rho_AB não é necessariamente uma
matriz densidade por si só, mas a matriz rho inteira é necessariamente uma matriz densidade. Quando aplicamos o canal fi ao
sistema X, ele é transformado em Y, e então ficamos com o par ZY, e a forma como determinamos
o estado desse par após aplicar fi apenas em X é avaliar o mapeamento linear fi em cada uma das matrizes rho_AB.
Outra forma de dizer isso é que tomamos o produto tensorial do mapeamento fi com o mapeamento identidade em matrizes quadradas com linhas e colunas
correspondentes a gamma, o que por sua vez corresponde a não fazer nada com o novo sistema Z. Mas essa é uma descrição equivalente
e não exige entrar em nenhum detalhe sobre produtos tensoriais de mapeamentos dessa forma. Eles
funcionam de um jeito bem direto, análogo ao como funcionam para vetores e matrizes. Uma forma de pensar sobre isso visualmente é
em termos de matrizes em bloco, e se fizermos a suposição simplificadora de que o conjunto de estados clássicos gamma consiste dos
inteiros entre 0 e N menos um para algum inteiro positivo M, então se torna fácil escrever tudo isso como mostrado
aqui. E agora para reiterar o requisito que estamos impondo sobre fi para que seja um canal válido: temos que sempre obter uma matriz densidade
a partir desse processo, e isso tem que ser verdadeiro independentemente da escolha que fazemos para o sistema Z, bem como da
escolha que fazemos para rho, desde que seja uma matriz densidade. Isso pode parecer um requisito bastante rígido e
também pode parecer muito difícil de verificar, mas como veremos ao final da aula, na verdade não é tão rígido
ou difícil de verificar, e em particular temos boas caracterizações matemáticas para essa condição
que estão conectadas às diferentes representações sobre as quais falaremos um pouco mais tarde na aula. Agora vamos ver alguns exemplos de canais,
começando com toda uma categoria de canais chamados canais unitários. Em termos simples, esses são operações unitárias,
assim como temos na formulação simplificada da informação quântica, vistos como canais. Para ser preciso, suponha que U seja uma matriz
unitária que representa uma operação unitária em um sistema X. Portanto, na formulação simplificada da informação quântica,
multiplicaríamos essa matriz por um dado vetor de estado quântico para determinar a ação que essa operação tem naquele estado quântico. A
forma como isso funciona para matrizes densidade é que multiplicamos a matriz densidade à esquerda por U e à direita por U
dagger. Em termos matemáticos, nos referimos a essa operação como conjugação pela matriz U. Isso é consistente com que
|ψ⟩⟨ψ| é a matriz densidade que descreve o estado representado pelo vetor de estado quântico ψ, e é bem
fácil de verificar que, em particular, se aplicássemos U ao vetor de estado quântico |ψ⟩, obteríamos U|ψ⟩, e sua
representação em matriz densidade é dada por esse vetor vezes seu transposto conjugado, que é U|ψ⟩⟨ψ|U
dagger, quando avaliamos o transposto conjugado de U|ψ⟩. Portanto, a forma como esse canal está definido
faz sentido para estados puros, e quando combinamos isso com a linearidade vemos que faz sentido para matrizes densidade em
geral, devido ao fato de que toda matriz densidade pode ser expressa como uma combinação convexa de estados puros.
Essa definição sempre nos dá um canal válido para qualquer escolha de operação unitária U. Em particular, conjugar por
uma matriz unitária assim não muda o traço de uma matriz, e se conjugarmos qualquer matriz semidefinida positiva
por qualquer matriz, obteremos outra matriz semidefinida positiva, e é bem fácil deduzir isso
diretamente da definição de matrizes semidefinidas positivas. Então as matrizes densidade sempre são mapeadas para matrizes densidade,
e tudo isso continua verdadeiro mesmo se tensoriarmos U com a matriz identidade de qualquer tamanho, o que é equivalente
a aplicar esse canal apenas a uma parte de um sistema composto. Aqui está um exemplo bem simples de um canal unitário. Suponha que
tomemos U como sendo a própria matriz identidade. Esse é obviamente um canal válido chamado canal identidade. Não fazer
absolutamente nada é certamente uma operação linear, e se começarmos com uma matriz densidade e não fizermos nada com ela,
ela ainda vai ser uma matriz densidade. Portanto, esse é um canal válido. As pessoas usam símbolos diferentes para denotar esse canal.
Às vezes é exatamente o mesmo símbolo que usamos para a matriz identidade, o que pode ser um pouco confuso, mas geralmente não é. Aqui estou usando
as letras ID, abreviação de identidade, apenas para evitar qualquer confusão, e essa notação também é bastante comum. Pode parecer um
canal muito chato, mas no contexto de transmissão de informação é na verdade um canal perfeito, onde o
receptor recebe exatamente o que o remetente envia, o que é tipicamente o que se quer na maioria das vezes nesse contexto. Outra forma de obter
muitos exemplos de canais é tomar combinações convexas de canais, ou em outras palavras, fazer a média deles
juntos, e o fato de que podemos fazer isso é um aspecto importante dos canais. Para explicar isso com mais detalhes, vamos começar com dois canais F0 e F1,
juntamente com um número real P entre 0 e 1, e só para ficar claro, estamos assumindo que esses dois canais têm
o mesmo sistema de entrada, que é X, bem como o mesmo sistema de saída, que é Y. E agora considere o que acontece se decidirmos
aplicar o primeiro canal F0 com probabilidade p e, caso contrário, com a probabilidade restante 1 menos p, aplicamos
o segundo canal F1. Por exemplo, talvez escolhamos aleatoriamente um bit com essas probabilidades e usemos esse bit aleatório
para determinar qual canal aplicar. Ao fazer isso, estamos efetivamente aplicando um novo canal, que podemos chamar de psi,
dado por uma combinação convexa dos dois canais com que começamos e que podemos expressar como mostrado
na tela. Sempre podemos tomar combinações lineares de mapeamentos lineares assim, e a forma como uma combinação linear
de mapeamentos lineares é definida em uma dada entrada é que simplesmente tomamos a mesma combinação linear das saídas.
Isso pode parecer um tanto trivial, mas faz sentido: a saída que obtemos desse cenário hipotético é simplesmente a
média ponderada das saídas que obteríamos dos dois canais originais. Ainda assim, esse é um novo canal, e
se fi0 e fi1 eram de fato canais válidos, então com certeza esse novo mapeamento também será um canal válido. Outra forma de dizer
isso em termos matemáticos é que o conjunto de todos os canais de um dado sistema de entrada para um dado sistema de saída é
convexo, e essa é uma propriedade matemática importante dos canais. Podemos fazer isso de forma mais geral: se temos M canais fi0 até fi M menos um,
junto com um vetor de probabilidade que nos diz qual é a probabilidade de cada canal, obtemos um novo canal fazendo a média dos canais de acordo. Então
em certo sentido, essa é uma fonte inesgotável de novos canais. Por exemplo, a classe dos chamados canais unitários mistos é o que
obtemos tomando combinações convexas de canais unitários. Ou seja, se temos M matrizes unitárias u0 até u M menos
um, todas do mesmo tamanho, junto com o vetor de probabilidade, então se tomarmos a média ponderada dos canais
correspondentes às matrizes unitárias individuais, como mostrado aqui na tela, obteremos um canal, e canais
que podem ser escritos assim são chamados de canais unitários mistos. Nem todo canal é um canal unitário misto — não conseguimos obter
todo canal dessa forma — mas eles aparecem bastante. A seguir, veremos alguns exemplos específicos
de canais. Todos estes serão exemplos de canais de um qubit para um qubit, que são chamados de canais de qubit
abreviadamente. O primeiro é chamado de canal de reset de qubit, e a ideia é que esse canal redefine um qubit
para o estado zero. Aqui estamos usando a letra grega maiúscula Lambda para denotar esse canal, e a forma de lembrar o que esse canal faz é
pensar na esfera de Bloch. Lambda maiúsculo parece uma seta apontando para cima, e o estado zero está no topo da esfera de Bloch, como se
estivesse apontando para a localização da saída. A forma como está definido em termos matemáticos é que Lambda de rho é igual ao traço de rho vezes |0⟩⟨0|. Então,
se avaliarmos em qualquer matriz densidade rho, obteremos o estado zero como matriz densidade. É natural se perguntar
por que precisamos do traço. Não poderíamos simplesmente definir Lambda de rho como |0⟩⟨0| sem o traço de rho na frente?
E a resposta para essa pergunta é não. Canais precisam ser mapeamentos lineares, e não seria linear se removêssemos o traço de rho. Além disso, tenha em mente que
às vezes precisamos saber como um canal funciona como mapeamento linear em entradas que não são matrizes densidade. Por exemplo, como
vimos anteriormente, se quisermos saber o que um canal faz quando o aplicamos a um sistema composto, precisamos
avaliar esse canal nos blocos individuais de uma matriz em bloco maior, e embora a matriz em bloco inteira possa ser
uma matriz densidade, os blocos individuais geralmente não serão. Então vamos ver exatamente o que esse canal faz quando o aplicamos
apenas a uma parte de um sistema composto, e mais especificamente o que faz quando o aplicamos a um dos dois qubits que
formam um ebit. Para ser preciso, suponha que A e B são qubits que, como par, estão no estado de Bell fi+ e aplicamos Lambda
digamos ao primeiro qubit A. Para descobrir o que acontece, vamos primeiro expressar o estado fi+ como uma matriz densidade e,
para fins desse exemplo, usaremos notação de Dirac para fazer isso. Aqui está o estado fi+ como vetor de estado quântico, e aqui está o que obtemos quando
multiplicamos esse vetor pelo seu transposto conjugado e expandimos tudo. Podemos então aplicar o canal ao primeiro qubit e avaliar o que obtemos. Aqui está
Lambda aplicado ao primeiro qubit, e aqui está o que obtemos quando avaliamos cada um dos termos. O traço de |0⟩⟨0| é um,
assim como o traço de |1⟩⟨1|. Portanto, nesses dois casos a saída do canal é |0⟩⟨0|, e isso explica
os dois termos na resposta. O traço de |0⟩⟨1|, por outro lado, é zero, assim como o traço de |1⟩⟨0|,
e então esses dois termos se avaliam a zero e, portanto, não contribuem em nada para a resposta. Podemos agora simplificar um
pouco e o que obtemos é o estado zero para o primeiro qubit A e o estado completamente misturado para o
segundo qubit B. Observe em particular que não obtivemos um estado plus para B, o que não seria necessariamente
um palpite ruim se não soubéssemos nada sobre matrizes densidade e olhássemos apenas para a representação do vetor de estado quântico do estado, mas isso
não é como esse canal funciona e não existe nenhum canal que poderia funcionar dessa forma. O canal Lambda é chamado de canal de reset de qubit, mas a
forma como funciona é mais parecida com jogar o qubit de entrada no lixo e substituí-lo por um qubit novo no estado zero. Mas esse é de fato o
único canal de qubit que sempre gera o estado zero. Aqui está outro exemplo de canal de qubit, conhecido como
canal de desfasamento completo. Esse é denotado por Delta, e a forma como funciona é que deixa as entradas da diagonal
de qualquer matriz 2x2 inalteradas e zera as entradas fora da diagonal. Delta é a letra grega equivalente do D no
alfabeto latino, e isso é abreviação de diagonal, então essa é uma forma de lembrar o que esse canal faz. Podemos
alternativamente expressar esse canal usando notação de Dirac como mostrado na tela, e só para ficar claro, a saída
é sempre uma matriz 2x2. Então, em particular, as saídas zero se referem à matriz 2x2 completamente nula. Frequentemente fazemos
isso e já vimos isso antes nesta série: o símbolo zero é geralmente usado, talvez de forma ambígua, para significar o elemento zero
de qualquer coisa de que estamos falando, seja escalares, vetores, matrizes ou o que for. Vamos fazer a mesma coisa que fizemos anteriormente para o
canal de reset de qubit e ver o que acontece se aplicarmos esse canal a metade de um ebit. A configuração é a mesma, então não vou
passar por essa parte, e o resultado é o estado mostrado na tela, que é essencialmente um bit aleatório compartilhado. Então o que
esse canal fez foi basicamente converter um ebit em um par perfeitamente correlacionado de bits aleatórios clássicos,
e isso é consistente com uma interpretação mais geral desse canal: ao zerar as entradas fora da diagonal de uma matriz densidade, estamos efetivamente
descartando a parte quântica de uma matriz densidade, deixando uma matriz densidade diagonal que representa um
estado probabilístico clássico. Outra forma de pensar sobre isso é que esse canal representa um canal clássico perfeito sem ruído que transmite um bit.
Então, se colocarmos um estado zero ou um estado um, ou uma combinação convexa desses dois estados no canal, esse estado sai inalterado. Mas se você tentar
colocar um estado quântico nele, como um estado plus, por exemplo, é como se o canal medisse esse estado com uma medição na base padrão e então
transmitisse o resultado clássico. Um último exemplo de canal de qubit é o canal de despolarização completa. O que
esse canal faz é sempre gerar o estado completamente misturado, então é similar em certo sentido ao canal de reset de qubit,
exceto que obtemos um estado completamente misturado — bem menos útil — em vez de um qubit inicializado. Uma forma natural
de pensar sobre esse canal é que ele representa uma forma extrema de ruído e, no que diz respeito a canais de qubit,
realmente não pode ficar mais ruidoso do que isso. Não tenho um bom mnemônico para lembrar o que esse faz, exceto dizer que Omega é a última
letra do alfabeto grego e às vezes é associada ao fim de todas as coisas, e talvez seja isso que acontece
com todos os qubits eventualmente. No que diz respeito ao ruído, é bastante extremo, mas uma coisa que podemos fazer é considerar uma combinação convexa
desse canal e do canal identidade com talvez uma pequena probabilidade épsilon para a despolarização completa.
Essa é uma forma menos extrema de ruído, onde um dado estado de qubit ficará majoritariamente inalterado, mas há
uma pequena chance de que fique completamente misturado. Geometricamente, podemos pensar nisso como uma leve contração da esfera de Bloch em direção ao centro.
Por sinal, podemos fazer algo similar com o canal de desfasamento completo para modelar o processo de decoerência, por exemplo, onde as coisas
ficam um pouco mais clássicas através de algum processo. Então esses são três exemplos básicos de canais de qubit, e
voltaremos a eles principalmente como fonte de exemplos ao longo do restante da aula. A seguir, discutiremos representações matemáticas
de canais, começando com uma questão básica: mapeamentos lineares de vetores para vetores podem sempre ser
representados por matrizes de uma forma familiar, que é que a ação do mapeamento linear é descrita pela multiplicação
de matriz por vetor. Mas canais são mapeamentos lineares de matrizes para matrizes, não de vetores para vetores. Então, em
geral, como podemos expressar canais em termos matemáticos? Às vezes, para canais especiais, teremos uma fórmula simples
que os descreve, e esse foi o caso nos exemplos de canais de qubit que já discutimos. Mas isso não é
prático em geral, porque nem sempre haverá uma fórmula tão agradável. Como ponto de comparação, na formulação simplificada
da informação quântica, usamos matrizes unitárias para representar operações em vetores de estado quântico.
Toda matriz unitária representa uma operação válida e toda operação válida pode ser expressa como uma matriz unitária. Então, em
essência, o que essa pergunta está perguntando é como fazemos isso para canais. E a resposta a essa pergunta é que há de fato múltiplas formas de representar
canais em termos matemáticos. Em particular, discutiremos três formas diferentes de representar canais, que são
nomeadas em homenagem a três indivíduos cujo trabalho teve um papel importante no seu desenvolvimento: Stinespring, Kraus e Choi.
Primeiro veremos como essas diferentes representações funcionam, e então na última parte da aula veremos como as três representações se relacionam e, em
particular, como podemos converter entre elas. Também veremos que essas representações capturam precisamente os requisitos que temos sobre canais,
a saber, que são mapeamentos lineares e que sempre transformam matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade, mesmo quando
aplicados a apenas uma parte de um sistema composto. Primeiro, temos as representações de Stinespring. Willam Forrest Stinespring
foi um matemático que não trabalhava com informação quântica, e as representações de Stinespring, como vou descrevê-las,
são de certa forma apenas um derivativo do seu trabalho em teoria de operadores na década de 1950. Mas esse trabalho foi certamente
uma parte importante do desenvolvimento da matemática em que os canais quânticos se baseiam. A ideia por trás dessa forma de representar canais é que todo
canal pode ser implementado de uma certa forma que descreverei agora. Primeiro, formamos um sistema composto consistindo da
entrada para qualquer canal que estamos implementando, junto com um sistema de espaço de trabalho inicializado. Em seguida, uma
operação unitária é realizada no sistema composto e, finalmente, qualquer parte do sistema composto resultante
que corresponde à saída do canal é deixada intacta ou enviada como saída, e o resto é descartado ou traçado. É útil
expressar isso na forma de um diagrama, e é mais simples começar com o caso especial em que os sistemas de entrada e
saída são os mesmos. Esse diagrama, aliás, é exatamente como um diagrama de circuit quântico, exceto que os fios
representam sistemas arbitrários e não necessariamente qubits individuais. Então começamos com o sistema de entrada X estando em algum
estado rho, introduzimos um sistema de espaço de trabalho inicializado W, e nesse diagrama estou presumindo que 0 é um estado clássico
de W e estamos tomando |0⟩ como o estado inicializado do sistema. Mas poderíamos alternativamente fixar qualquer estado puro
de W e vê-lo como o estado inicializado. Em seguida, executamos alguma operação unitária no par WX e então
traçamos o sistema de espaço de trabalho e geramos X como saída. Aqui no diagrama, aliás, estou usando o símbolo de aterramento da
engenharia elétrica para indicar que W está sendo descartado. Isso não é necessariamente convencional e não
vai encontrar esse símbolo no Qiskit — lá você simplesmente ignora os qubits pelos quais não está interessado. O ponto é que eu quero apenas ter um símbolo que deixe
claro que estamos descartando o sistema para os propósitos dessa discussão. Em geral, não precisamos necessariamente que os
sistemas de entrada e saída sejam os mesmos, então podemos ter, por exemplo, um sistema de saída Y junto com um
sistema de lixo G que é traçado. Para que U seja unitária, ela tem que ser uma matriz quadrada, portanto há uma suposição
aqui de que o par G, Y juntos tem o mesmo número de estados clássicos que o par WX. Por exemplo, talvez esses sistemas
consistam de qubits e o sistema de entrada X consista de 5 qubits e W consista de 10 qubits. Então U é uma operação unitária
em 15 qubits. Poderia então ser que Y consiste de apenas 4 qubits, o que significa que G consiste de 11 qubits,
ou talvez esses não sejam qubits de jeito nenhum. O que importa é que WX juntos e GY juntos tenham o mesmo número de
estados clássicos para que U possa ser unitária. Uma descrição de um canal assim é chamada de representação de Stinespring do canal. Agora é
bem direto argumentar que qualquer mapeamento fi que pode ser descrito dessa forma é de fato um canal válido. Em
particular, se começarmos com a matriz densidade e depois acrescentarmos um sistema de espaço de trabalho adicional, certamente
ficaremos com uma matriz densidade. Já observamos que aplicar uma operação unitária nos dá um canal válido, e
se temos uma matriz densidade de um sistema composto e traçamos um dos sistemas, também ficaremos com uma matriz densidade. Então, quando compomos
essas etapas, teremos a garantia de que sempre transforma matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade, e também é linear.
O que não está nada claro neste ponto é que todo canal pode de fato ser implementado dessa forma para alguma escolha
do sistema de espaço de trabalho e do sistema de lixo, bem como da operação unitária U. Mas isso é verdade e
veremos por quê ao final da aula. Aqui está um exemplo de representação de Stinespring para o canal de qubit de desfasamento completo,
e só para ficar claro, agora os fios são qubits e este é um gate CNOT ordinário
controlado. É muito simples: o qubit de entrada está no topo e introduzimos um qubit de espaço de trabalho inicializado no estado zero.
Em seguida, executamos um gate CNOT onde o qubit de entrada é o controle e o qubit de espaço de trabalho é o
alvo, e então o qubit de espaço de trabalho é traçado. Intuitivamente falando, faz sentido
que isso implemente o canal de desfasamento completo, porque o gate CNOT age como uma medição na base padrão sobre o qubit do topo,
copiando seu estado clássico para o qubit de baixo, e então o resultado é descartado.
Mas também podemos fazer o cálculo, e é claro que é uma boa ideia fazê-lo, porque realmente
não devemos confiar demais na nossa intuição. Podemos começar escrevendo a representação em matriz densidade dos
dois qubits após o qubit de espaço de trabalho ter sido introduzido, e observe que estamos usando a convenção de ordenação de qubits
como de costume, onde o qubit de baixo é o da esquerda e o qubit de cima está à direita. Podemos expressar essa matriz densidade
explicitamente como uma matriz 4x4 real, como mostrado na tela, e então calculamos o efeito
que o gate CNOT tem sobre essa matriz densidade. Portanto, conjugamos pela matriz unitária associada a esse
gate, tendo em mente novamente a convenção de ordenação de qubits. Então essa é a matriz unitária correta,
e o resultado é mostrado aqui. Na prática, o gate CNOT
permutou as entradas da nossa matriz original um pouco, de modo que agora as entradas possivelmente não nulas estão nos
quatro cantos. Resta calcular o traço parcial, e poderíamos fazer isso diretamente a partir da matriz, mas uma
alternativa é converter para a notação de Dirac como mostrado na tela, e então se torna bem fácil avaliar
o que acontece quando traçamos o qubit da esquerda dentro de cada termo. O resultado é que apenas os
termos correspondentes às entradas da diagonal de rho sobrevivem, e assim desfasamos o qubit como
esperado. Como sempre, verifique isso por conta própria no seu próprio ritmo se quiser. É um bom
exemplo para praticar o trabalho com matrizes densidade e com traços
parciais. Essa não é a única forma de implementar o canal de desfasamento completo. Aqui está uma representação de Stinespring alternativa para esse
canal. Não vou passar pelo cálculo em detalhes neste vídeo, mas vou mostrá-lo brevemente caso você queira pausar o vídeo e dar uma
olhada mais detalhada. A forma como funciona é similar à primeira, mas os detalhes são
diferentes. Desta vez, começamos com um gate Hadamard no qubit de espaço de trabalho, que o coloca em um estado plus. E se
expandirmos o produto tensorial, obtemos a matriz mostrada na tela. Para aplicar o gate de controle Z,
conjugamos pela matriz unitária associada, e o resultado disso é injetar alguns sinais negativos na
matriz. Em particular, a última linha e a última coluna são multiplicadas por menos 1.
E desta vez seria muito bagunçado converter para a notação de Dirac, então calcularemos o traço parcial
diretamente. Quando traçamos o primeiro de dois qubits, o que acabamos obtendo é a soma dos dois blocos 2x2 diagonais,
e o resultado final é novamente que desfasamos o qubit. Isso foi rápido, e se você não
está acostumado com esse tipo de cálculo, tome seu tempo e faça devagar. Velocidade não é importante
aqui. Para finalizar este exemplo, deixa eu mencionar que há uma ideia bem simples por trás dessa implementação, que é
bem expressa pelo último passo do cálculo que acabamos de percorrer rapidamente. Uma forma mais sucinta de dizer isso
é que se fizermos a média de uma dada matriz densidade de qubit com essa matriz densidade conjugada pela matriz de Pauli Z, então
isso é a mesma coisa que desfasar. Portanto, o canal de desfasamento completo acontece de ser um canal unitário misto
onde ou não fazemos nada — ou seja, realizamos a operação identidade — ou realizamos um gate Z, cada um
com probabilidade 1/2. Bom saber. Então, em resumo, temos duas representações de Stinespring diferentes
do canal de desfasamento completo, e isso nos diz algo importante: que as representações de Stinespring
não são únicas e, de fato, existem infinitas delas para qualquer canal dado. A seguir, discutimos as representações de Kraus
de canais, que nos oferecem uma forma conveniente e formulaica de expressar canais através de
multiplicação e adição de matrizes. As representações de Kraus têm o nome de Karl Kraus, que é um físico que, entre
outras coisas, trabalhou em vários detalhes matemáticos básicos de canais e da formulação geral da informação quântica de forma mais ampla. Em geral, uma
representação de Kraus é uma expressão de um canal na forma mostrada aqui na tela. Em particular, temos uma
coleção de matrizes, aqui denominadas A_0 até A_ para algum inteiro positivo n, e elas especificam
a ação do canal em qualquer entrada rho de acordo com a fórmula. Em resumo, conjugamos rho por cada uma dessas matrizes,
que são frequentemente chamadas de matrizes de Kraus neste contexto, e somamos o resultado, e isso nos dá a saída. Todas essas matrizes devem ter
as mesmas dimensões e, especificamente, suas colunas devem corresponder aos estados clássicos do sistema de entrada e
as linhas devem corresponder aos estados clássicos do sistema de saída. Se esse for o caso, quando tomarmos o produto A_K * rho * A_K dagger para qualquer
escolha de K, obteremos uma matriz quadrada cujas linhas e colunas correspondem aos estados clássicos do sistema de saída,
e portanto faz sentido que a expressão produza uma matriz densidade do sistema de saída. Agora, não é o caso
que para uma escolha arbitrária dessas matrizes de Kraus tenhamos um canal válido. Há, porém, uma condição bastante simples
sobre as matrizes que garante que obteremos um canal válido, e essa condição é a fórmula exibida aqui.
Especificamente, se somarmos o produto de A_K dagger * A_K sobre todos os valores de K,
devemos obter a matriz identidade, que será a matriz identidade cujas linhas e colunas correspondem aos
estados clássicos do sistema de entrada. Então essa condição deve ser satisfeita para que o mapeamento definido pela
primeira equação seja um canal válido. E acontece que todo canal tem de fato uma representação que toma
essa forma, desde que tomemos n grande o suficiente. Aqui estão alguns exemplos de representações de Kraus,
começando com o canal de reset de qubit. Podemos obter uma representação de Kraus para esse canal usando
duas matrizes de Kraus: |0⟩⟨0| e |0⟩⟨1|. Então n é igual a dois nesse exemplo.
Podemos substituir essas escolhas na fórmula geral e temos apenas dois termos, então é fácil escrever a soma.
E se simplificarmos e reconhecermos que a expressão entre parênteses é o traço de rho, veremos que obtemos
o canal de reset de qubit. Também podemos verificar que a condição requerida sobre essas matrizes é satisfeita, e é uma simples questão de substituir as matrizes de Kraus
na equação e avaliar, e obtemos a matriz identidade como requerido. Para outro exemplo, vamos novamente dar uma olhada no
canal de desfasamento completo. Tomar as matrizes |0⟩⟨0| e |1⟩⟨1| funciona, e isso pode ser verificado
expandindo a soma e vendo diretamente que obtemos o que precisamos, e novamente a condição requerida é satisfeita. Uma
alternativa é tomar A_0 como sendo a matriz identidade dividida por √2 e A_1 como
sigma_Z dividida por √2, e se avaliarmos veremos que novamente obtemos o canal de desfasamento completo, baseado na observação
que fizemos sobre esse canal um pouco antes na aula, e mais uma vez a condição requerida é bastante direta de
verificar. Como exercício para trabalhar caso você ache útil, considere o canal de despolarização completa,
que gera o estado completamente misturado para toda entrada de matriz densidade. Para esse, são necessárias quatro matrizes de Kraus.
Não é possível chegar a uma representação de Kraus onde n seja três ou menos. Aqui está uma escolha que funciona e
aqui está outra. O exercício é verificar que essas escolhas funcionam, bem como verificar que a condição requerida
é satisfeita. Vale destacar que a segunda alternativa basicamente diz que é possível despolarizar completamente um qubit — ou em outras palavras,
aleatorizar completamente — escolhendo aleatoriamente uma das quatro matrizes de Pauli, incluindo a identidade, e aplicando a
operação unitária correspondente ao qubit. Portanto, o canal de despolarização completa é outro exemplo de canal unitário misto.
A última das três representações de canal que abordaremos é a representação de Choi. Man-Duen Choi
é um matemático que trabalha em teoria de matrizes e outros tópicos, e a representação de Choi tem esse nome em sua homenagem,
baseada em um artigo muito elegante que ele publicou em 1975, que de certa forma une tudo isso. A representação de Choi
de um canal fi é uma única matriz que convencionalmente é denotada J_fi, e especificamente se o
sistema de entrada tem n estados clássicos e o sistema de saída tem M estados clássicos, então a representação de Choi de fi será
uma matriz quadrada n*M por n*M. Antes de te dizer exatamente como a matriz está definida, gostaria de mencionar alguns dos
seus propriedades chave, que motivam a representação de uma forma que a definição real em si pode não fazer — pelo menos na
superfície. Primeiro, ao contrário tanto das representações de Stinespring quanto das representações de Kraus, a representação de Choi
é uma chamada representação fiel, o que significa que todo canal tem exatamente uma, e isso é bastante importante,
pois diz que dois canais são iguais se e somente se suas representações de Choi são iguais. Então, se você
tiver duas descrições diferentes de canais — como duas representações de Stinespring diferentes ou duas representações de Kraus diferentes, ou talvez uma de
cada — e quiser saber se são de fato o mesmo canal, pode simplesmente calcular a representação de Choi e
verificar se são iguais. A segunda propriedade é que existem condições simples de verificar na representação de Choi que são verdadeiras se e somente se
temos um canal válido. Essa propriedade não é tão especial — podemos dizer o mesmo sobre as outras duas representações — mas é uma boa propriedade
de se ter de qualquer maneira, e discutiremos isso mais detalhadamente em breve. Mais uma coisa a observar sobre a representação de Choi é que, embora estejamos
representando um canal por uma matriz, essa matriz não representa diretamente o canal como mapeamento linear. Na verdade,
é mais natural associar a representação de Choi com a matriz densidade que representa um certo estado
do que pensar na representação de Choi como descrevendo um mapeamento linear. É no entanto possível recuperar a ação do canal a partir da
sua representação de Choi usando uma fórmula bastante simples, mas não é tão simples quanto a multiplicação de matrizes ordinária.
Chega de preâmbulo; vamos à definição real. Suponha que temos um canal fi de um sistema X para um sistema Y,
e assuma que o conjunto de estados clássicos do sistema de entrada X é Sigma. Não precisaremos nos referir ao conjunto de estados clássicos do sistema de saída, então
para a definição não há necessidade de nomeá-lo. A representação de Choi de fi é então definida pela expressão
mostrada aqui na tela. Temos uma soma que varia sobre todos os estados clássicos A e B do sistema de entrada, e estamos
somando |a⟩⟨b| tensorado com o canal fi aplicado a |a⟩⟨b|. Então essa
representação é definida por uma fórmula, e há algumas formas diferentes de pensar sobre essa fórmula. Antes de discuti-las, porém, deixa eu
mencionar que às vezes a representação de Choi é definida de uma forma ligeiramente diferente, onde a ordenação dos dois fatores tensoriais é invertida, significando
que fi de |a⟩⟨b| aparece como o primeiro fator tensorial em vez do segundo. Mas as duas formas diferentes de fazer isso são
equivalentes até essa simetria simples. O que isso significa é que quando você está usando essa representação, é uma boa
ideia esclarecer qual ordenação você está usando. Essa ordenação é a forma como é feita no Qiskit, e também é melhor para
descrever a representação visualmente em termos de matrizes em bloco. Então essa é a que vou adotar. Para ser mais preciso sobre a descrição em matriz em bloco:
se assumirmos que o conjunto de estados clássicos Sigma consiste dos inteiros de zero até n menos um
para algum inteiro positivo n, podemos alternativamente escrever J_fi como uma matriz em bloco como mostrado aqui na
tela. Em outras palavras, a representação de Choi de fi é a matriz que obtemos avaliando fi em cada uma das
matrizes de entrada que têm exatamente uma entrada igual a um com todas as demais entradas iguais a zero, e então organizando-as
em uma matriz de uma forma bem natural. Pode não ficar claro a priori por que queremos formar uma matriz assim, mas
acaba sendo muito útil. Uma coisa a notar é que o conjunto contendo as matrizes |a⟩⟨b| à medida que
a e b variam sobre todos os inteiros de 0 a n menos um forma uma base para o espaço de todas as matrizes n por n. Então se
você tem essa matriz, certamente pode determinar o que fi faz com uma matriz n por n arbitrária por linearidade,
especificamente tomando combinações lineares apropriadas dos blocos. Então a matriz J_fi de fato determina uniquamente
fi como mapeamento linear. Outra forma de pensar sobre a representação de Choi de um canal é que
ela representa um estado como matriz densidade quando é normalizada — especificamente dividindo-a pelo número de
estados clássicos do sistema de entrada, que continuarei denotando por n minúsculo. Isso sempre nos dará uma
matriz densidade, frequentemente chamada de estado de Choi do canal. Aqui está como isso funciona em mais detalhes:
imagine primeiro que temos duas cópias idênticas do sistema de entrada e consideramos o vetor de estado quântico s
mostrado na tela, que representa um chamado estado maximamente entrelaçado desse par de sistemas idênticos. Por
exemplo, se Sigma for o alfabeto binário, então esse é um estado fi+, mas podemos pensar em um estado definido de forma análoga para
qualquer escolha de Sigma, e o que obtemos é um estado altamente entrelaçado, e de fato é tão entrelaçado quanto se pode ser
dada essa escolha de sistemas. Para obter a representação em matriz densidade do estado, multiplicamos o vetor de estado pelo seu transposto conjugado como de costume, e
é assim que parece. E finalmente, se pensarmos sobre a representação de Choi do canal dividida por n, veremos que é o estado que
obteríamos se aplicássemos o canal fi ao segundo sistema. Na forma de uma figura, aqui está
como isso parece: temos duas cópias do sistema X nesse estado maximamente entrelaçado s. O canal fi é
aplicado ao segundo sistema, que é o do topo no diagrama, e o estado resultante é o estado de Choi de fi. Claro, normalmente não
daríamos o mesmo nome a dois sistemas diferentes. Geralmente não é útil dar o mesmo nome a duas coisas diferentes, mas faz sentido
nesse caso, apenas para fazer essa conexão com as representações de Choi. Há algumas implicações que podemos imediatamente tirar dessa forma de
pensar sobre as representações de Choi. Uma delas é que, como o estado de Choi é uma matriz densidade, assumindo que fi é um
canal válido, concluímos que a representação de Choi de fi deve ser semidefinida positiva. Lembrando que é um
requisito que impomos aos canais que eles sempre transformem matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade, e esse
é apenas um caso especial disso. A segunda implicação é que, se tomarmos o estado de Choi de qualquer canal fi e
então descartarmos o sistema de saída Y, devemos ficar com o estado completamente misturado no sistema de entrada X. Isso
ocorre porque aplicar um canal a um sistema e depois jogar o sistema resultante fora é equivalente a simplesmente jogar o sistema original
fora. E se fizéssemos isso com nosso estado maximamente entrelaçado, a matriz densidade com que ficaríamos seria
a matriz identidade dividida por n — ou seja, o estado completamente misturado para o sistema X. A ideia em termos mais
matemáticos é que compor qualquer canal com o traço no sistema de saída deve ser igual ao traço no
sistema de entrada, pois os canais devem preservar o traço por virtude do fato de serem mapeamentos lineares que
sempre transformam matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade. Uma vez que temos essa equação, podemos limpar o denominador n
de ambos os lados para obter uma condição ligeiramente mais limpa. Em palavras, realizar o traço parcial no sistema de saída
da representação de Choi de um canal deve nos dar a matriz identidade no sistema de entrada. Então, em resumo, as representações de Choi
de canais são sempre semidefinidas positivas e, se traçarmos o sistema de saída, necessariamente
ficamos com a matriz identidade no sistema de entrada. Acontece que essas não são apenas condições necessárias, mas
também são suficientes, o que significa que se fi é algum mapeamento linear arbitrário e essas duas condições acontecem de ser
verdadeiras, então deve ser de fato que fi é um canal válido. E veremos por que esse é o caso ao final da aula.
Vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos, começando com o canal de desfasamento completo. Para calcular a representação de Choi é simplesmente uma questão de
avaliar a fórmula. O canal de desfasamento completo deixa |a⟩⟨b| inalterado quando a é igual a b, e caso contrário a saída
é zero. Portanto, os termos da soma que sobrevivem são aqueles onde a é igual a b, e o resultado é expresso na
tela usando notação de Dirac. Também podemos vê-lo como uma matriz em bloco. Delta deixa as entradas diagonais inalteradas e zera as fora
da diagonal, e portanto ficamos com uma matriz com uns no canto superior esquerdo e inferior direito, com todas as
demais entradas iguais a zero, e isso é consistente com a primeira expressão. Para outro exemplo, vamos considerar novamente o canal de despolarização completa.
Podemos começar escrevendo a fórmula e, assim como no exemplo anterior, não obtemos nenhuma contribuição para a soma
quando a não é igual a b. E desta vez, quando a é igual a b, obtemos o estado completamente misturado e podemos simplificar isso para
obter 1/2 vezes a matriz identidade 2x2 tensorada com ela mesma, que é 1/2 vezes a matriz identidade
4x4. Também podemos pensar sobre isso em termos de matrizes em bloco e naturalmente obtemos o mesmo resultado. E como
último exemplo, vamos considerar o canal identidade para um único qubit. É um fácil. Aqui está a fórmula e
claro que o canal identidade não faz nada, e podemos pensar no resultado como sendo o dobro da matriz densidade associada a um estado fi+, e isso é
consistente com o que esperamos ao pensar no estado de Choi desse canal. E aqui está como uma matriz em bloco. Observe em particular que a representação de Choi
do canal identidade não é a matriz identidade — é essa matriz. Vimos agora três formas diferentes
de representar canais em termos matemáticos: representações de Stinespring, representações de Kraus e representações de Choi.
Também temos a definição de um canal, que é que um canal é um mapeamento linear que sempre
transforma matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade, mesmo quando o canal é aplicado a apenas uma parte de um sistema composto. Uma pergunta muito natural e muito importante
a fazer neste ponto é: como sabemos que todas essas coisas são equivalentes? Por exemplo, como sabemos que todo
mapeamento descrito por qualquer uma dessas representações é de fato um canal válido? E como sabemos que não estamos deixando nenhum canal de fora?
O restante da aula descreve como tudo isso pode ser raciocínado matematicamente. Se você estiver disposto a aceitar a equivalência dessas coisas e não estiver interessado em como isso pode
ser raciocínado, sinta-se à vontade para pular o restante do vídeo. Mas pessoalmente acho que o argumento é bastante
elegante e é um bom exemplo de um estilo particular de prova matemática que surge de tempos em tempos na teoria da informação quântica. Não vou
abordar todos os detalhes — alguns deles deixarei para você, ou você pode encontrá-los no conteúdo escrito desta aula, onde tudo está escrito em
detalhes. Mas espero apresentar um quadro razoavelmente claro de como tudo funciona. O que queremos fazer é provar a
equivalência de uma coleção de declarações, e a forma de fazer isso é estabelecer um ciclo de implicações. Em particular, começaremos
com a definição de um canal, ou seja, um mapeamento linear que sempre transforma matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade.
A partir dessa definição, podemos raciocinar que a representação de Choi desse canal deve satisfazer as duas condições que
já identificamos. E de fato já fizemos isso: foi discutido no contexto do estado de Choi de um canal. Em seguida, esquecemos tudo
sobre a definição e trabalhamos a partir da representação de Choi, e dadas as duas condições sobre as representações de Choi, concluímos que deve existir uma
representação de Kraus do mapeamento fi. Em seguida, fazemos uma coisa análoga: esquecemos as representações de Choi e trabalhamos
a partir de uma representação de Kraus arbitrária, e a partir dela podemos raciocinar que deve haver uma representação de Stinespring para o mapeamento fi. E a propósito, esses
argumentos serão de certa forma mecânicos, o que nos permite de fato realizar as conversões de acordo com as setas para canais específicos, se quisermos
fazer isso. A última implicação é raciocinar que se temos uma representação de Stinespring para um mapeamento fi, então
esse mapeamento deve de fato ser um canal válido. E novamente já fizemos isso, desta vez no contexto das representações de Stinespring.
Em conjunto, essas quatro implicações revelam que essas quatro coisas são todas equivalentes, porque você pode começar de qualquer uma delas e
seguir as implicações transitivamente para chegar a qualquer uma das outras. Começaremos com a primeira implicação,
que é que, se temos um canal fi — ou seja, um mapeamento linear que sempre transforma matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade — então ele tem uma representação de Choi
que satisfaz as duas condições que identificamos anteriormente, a saber, que é semidefinida positiva
e que se traçarmos o sistema de saída obtemos a identidade no sistema de entrada. E como mencionei há pouco,
já cobrimos essa implicação no contexto dos estados de Choi. Em particular, quando dividimos a representação de Choi de um canal por n — o número de
estados clássicos do sistema de entrada — obtemos uma matriz densidade, e além disso o estado reduzido do
sistema de entrada X para esse estado é o estado completamente misturado — ou seja, a matriz identidade dividida por n. Limpar o denominador nos dá nossas
duas condições. Portanto, essa implicação é bem rápida e fácil, porque já cobrimos
isso. Agora vamos dar uma olhada na segunda implicação. Desta vez começamos com a representação de Choi de um mapeamento, que
assumimos que satisfaz os dois requisitos, e nosso objetivo é chegar a uma representação de Kraus para esse mapeamento que
satisfaça o requisito que discutimos anteriormente. Essa implicação é bem mecânica em certo sentido. Precisaremos de um
pouco de álgebra linear, e isso principalmente se resumirá a manipular matrizes e vetores de uma forma bastante inteligente.
Começa com a suposição de que a representação de Choi é semidefinida positiva, que é o primeiro dos dois requisitos que estamos assumindo estão
em vigor. A noção de matriz semidefinida positiva é fundamentalmente importante em informação quântica e não apenas no contexto de matrizes densidade.
É absolutamente crítica aqui — não conseguiríamos fazer isso funcionar sem ela. Em particular, a suposição
de que J_fi é semidefinida positiva nos permite expressá-la na forma mostrada na tela para alguma escolha de
vetores s_0 até s_ e alguma escolha de inteiro positivo n. Deixa eu notar explicitamente que esses são
não necessariamente vetores unitários. Uma forma de obtermos uma expressão como essa é pelo teorema espectral para matrizes
semidefinidas positivas, que foi discutido na aula anterior. Aqui não vemos os autovalores aparecendo explicitamente como tínhamos em uma decomposição espectral,
mas lembre que os autovalores de matrizes semidefinidas positivas são sempre números reais não negativos. E também tenha em mente que não
estamos exigindo que esses vetores s_0 até s_ sejam vetores unitários. Então o que podemos fazer é tomar as raízes quadradas dos
autovalores e multiplicá-las nos autovetores unitários que obtemos de uma decomposição espectral para obter esses
vetores s_0 até s_. Na verdade, não é importante para essa prova que esses vetores sejam ortogonais — obtemos
isso de uma decomposição espectral, mas não vamos usar isso aqui. E se tivéssemos alguma expressão diferente de J_fi assim, que não viesse do
teorema espectral, também estaria tudo bem. Agora decompõe cada um desses vetores como mostrado na tela, e
isso é exatamente como faríamos se esses vetores fossem vetores de estado quântico de um par de sistemas XY e estivéssemos
realizando uma medição na base padrão no sistema X. Para ficar claro, não estamos medindo nada aqui, estamos apenas escrevendo esses vetores nessa forma, que
é sempre possível. E agora vem o truque: definimos matrizes de Kraus a_0 até a_ arrancando os K_A's
da frente desses vetores s_0 até s_, virando-os de modo que se tornem ⟨a|'s em vez de
|a⟩'s, e colocando-os para o lado direito como mostrado na equação na tela. Uma forma de pensar
sobre isso é que estamos basicamente dobrando esses vetores para formar matrizes, de modo que se empilhássemos as colunas de A_K umas sobre as outras,
obteríamos de volta s_K. Portanto, essas matrizes têm exatamente as mesmas entradas que os vetores correspondentes, mas apenas
reorganizamos as entradas de forma diferente para obtermos matrizes. Mas também podemos pensar sobre essas matrizes de forma puramente simbólica em termos de notação de Dirac,
como escrito aqui. E agora a essa altura há uma pergunta óbvia: por que isso deve funcionar? Bem, não vamos nos deter muito em
por que funciona; vamos apenas verificar que funciona. Para fazer isso, vamos definir um novo mapeamento, que é o mapeamento definido por
essas matrizes onde as estamos tratando como matrizes de Kraus. O que agora podemos fazer é calcular a representação de Choi de
esse novo mapeamento, e veremos que é igual à representação de Choi do mapeamento fi com que começamos. E
como as representações de Choi são fiéis, isso significa que os dois mapeamentos são de fato iguais. Não vou passar pela álgebra neste vídeo;
você pode verificar isso por conta própria. É bem mecânico e é uma boa prática, e tudo que você precisa para isso está logo
aqui na tela. Ainda não dissemos nada sobre as duas segundas condições nas duas caixas, mas
acabam sendo equivalentes, e uma forma de estabelecer isso é verificar a equação exibida aqui na parte inferior da
tela. A letra T aqui, a propósito, se refere à transposição de matrizes, que você pode alternativamente pensar como o
mapeamento linear que transforma |a⟩⟨b| em |b⟩⟨a|, e é apenas algo necessário para fazer a fórmula funcionar. Então, em
resumo, há definitivamente alguma álgebra necessária para essa implicação, mas como eu disse, é tudo bem mecânico.
Basicamente ginástica de índices, como algumas pessoas se referem a esse tipo de coisa. Mas se você trabalhar nisso e der ao seu cérebro a chance de digerir, pode descobrir
que sai com um melhor entendimento de como as representações de Choi e as representações de Kraus se relacionam. A terceira implicação nos permite
ir de uma representação de Kraus de um mapeamento fi, onde a condição usual está em vigor, para uma representação de Stinespring. Essa é bastante
similar em espírito à implicação anterior no sentido de que é mecânica e pode ser vista e verificada em termos puramente algébricos. A
ideia é na verdade bem simples: o que podemos fazer é pegar nossas matrizes de Kraus e formar parte de uma matriz maior empilhando-as
umas sobre as outras, como mostrado na tela. Uma vez preenchida, isso nos dará a matriz unitária U para uma
representação de Stinespring. Matrizes unitárias precisam ser matrizes quadradas, então teremos que preencher quantas
colunas restantes precisarmos. Mas na verdade não fará diferença o que elas são, desde que obtenhamos uma matriz
unitária. Se por um momento deixarmos de lado a preocupação de que U seja unitária e nos concentrarmos apenas no mapeamento linear que é definido pela
representação de Stinespring que obtemos dessa matriz U, descobriremos que o mapeamento é igual ao
mapeamento original fi definido pela representação de Kraus com que começamos. Essa é outra parte da prova que não vou abordar neste vídeo; você pode
encontrar os detalhes no conteúdo escrito desta aula. Mas pode alternativamente querer tomar algum tempo e trabalhar nisso por conta própria. Apenas lembre-se
que, como de costume para a série, estamos usando a convenção de ordenação de kets para interpretar o diagrama, então W e G vão
corresponder aos fatores tensoriais do lado esquerdo nas equações. E a propósito, se você
trabalhar nisso, descobrirá que, como temos |0⟩⟨0| como o fator tensorial do lado esquerdo na equação
que precisamos verificar, a única parte de U que tem alguma relevância é a parte dada pelas matrizes de Kraus. Então, desde que preenchamos
as colunas de U de uma forma que a torne unitária, estamos bem. Mas é claro que isso exige que as colunas formadas por a_0 até a_
quando as empilhamos umas sobre as outras sejam ortonormais, e é aqui que a condição que impomos sobre as representações de Kraus entra em jogo.
E de fato é precisamente equivalente a as colunas serem ortonormais. As relações matemáticas relevantes necessárias para tirar essa
conclusão são mostradas aqui na parte inferior da tela. Então vá em frente e pause e verifique se quiser, ou novamente
consulte o conteúdo escrito para mais detalhes. Em resumo, o que está acontecendo aqui tanto nessa implicação quanto na
anterior é que estamos descrevendo as mesmas operações matemáticas de formas diferentes mas equivalentes. O
coração pulsante de tudo isso é essencialmente a multiplicação de matrizes. A quarta e última implicação estabelece que se temos
uma representação de Stinespring para algum mapeamento, então esse mapeamento deve de fato ser um canal válido. E como indiquei
anteriormente, já cobrimos essa implicação quando discutimos as representações de Stinespring. Em resumo e em
outros termos: introduzir um sistema de espaço de trabalho inicializado é um canal válido. Isso ocorre porque tensorar uma matriz densidade fixada
a uma dada matriz densidade sempre nos dá uma matriz densidade, e é um mapeamento linear pela bilinearidade
dos produtos tensoriais. Operações unitárias são sempre canais válidos, como discuti anteriormente na aula. Traçar um sistema é um canal válido porque o
traço parcial é um mapeamento linear que sempre transforma matrizes densidade em matrizes densidade. E finalmente, composições de
canais são sempre canais, o que é bem simples, mas definitivamente vale observar por si só. E com as
quatro implicações que acabamos de cobrir, estabelecemos a equivalência das nossas três representações de canal juntamente com a
definição original de um canal. Em particular, começamos com a definição de um canal e vimos como essa definição implica que sua representação de Choi
necessariamente satisfaz duas condições básicas. Então vimos como essas condições nos permitem encontrar uma representação de Kraus, que por sua vez
nos permite encontrar uma representação de Stinespring. E finalmente vimos que a existência de uma representação de Stinespring revela que de fato temos
um canal válido. Claro que há detalhes técnicos aqui, e não é necessariamente simples, especialmente
quando você está vendo pela primeira vez. Mas o que é interessante e digno de nota aqui é que essas implicações são configuradas de uma forma que de fato torna
as coisas o mais fáceis possível. E em matemática, você nunca deve sentir vergonha de pegar o caminho mais fácil.
Por exemplo, não é nada óbvio que todo canal tenha uma representação de Stinespring ou uma representação de Kraus,
mas é relativamente fácil concluir que a representação de Choi de todo canal satisfaz as duas condições que associamos a ela. E isso
nos permite seguir um caminho mais ou menos algébrico para as outras duas representações. Da mesma forma, a
última implicação — de uma representação de Stinespring de volta à definição — também é relativamente direta, e isso
nos permite concluir que obtemos apenas canais e nenhum outro mapeamento das representações de Choi, assumindo que as
condições requeridas sejam satisfeitas. E como aludi antes, a forma como argumentamos essas implicações é suficientemente mecânica para nos permitir facilmente converter
entre as representações. E se você voltar a alguns dos exemplos que cobrimos anteriormente na aula, descobrirá que é de fato possível
converter entre as representações, às vezes de forma bem fácil e direta. E esse é o fim da
aula, que foi toda sobre canais. Falamos sobre o que são e demos uma olhada em alguns exemplos básicos. Discutimos três formas de representar canais
e mergulhamos em alguns detalhes técnicos que estabelecem a equivalência dessas representações.
Espero que você se junte a mim na próxima aula, que é toda sobre medições na formulação geral da informação quântica. Até a próxima!